le président du Sénat
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés
mesdames et messieurs
pour que la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale prenne la parole dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat
il faut un grand événement
[Musique]
et c'est un effet un moment historique
que nous vivons et un grand honneur que
vous nous faites votre majesté qui
connaît bien la France mais qui vient
pour la première fois en tant que
souverain du Royaume-Uni de
Grande-Bretagne et d'Irlande du Nord
cette visite se devait de comporter une
dimension parlementaire
car il faut le reconnaître si le
Royaume-Uni réclamait des royalties sur
l'idée du Parlement toutes les
démocraties du monde lui seraient
redevable
en France
dès le siècle des Lumières le partage du
pouvoir entre exécutif et législatif et
l'admiration des esprits éclairés
si Montesquieu théorise la séparation
des pouvoirs il en observe la pratique
de l'autre côté de la Manche et c'est
aussi à Londres que Voltaire puis
l'inspiration de ses lettres anglaises
Mirabeau quant à lui plusieurs fois
victimes de l'arbitraire royal vénère
tout particulièrement la Béa Scorpus
britannique et c'est donc sous le titre
d'observation d'un voyage anglais qu'il
publie sa critique des prisons d'État
françaises
dans ce livre il crédite nos voisins vos
sujets
d'un plus grand respect des droits de
l'homme que cette nation a si
glorieusement appris
allusion évidente à la Glorieuse
Révolution de 1688
lui-même publie son pamphlet un siècle
plus tard en 1788 et si l'année suivante
la volonté le même Mirabeau défi le roi
du France en lui opposant la volonté du
peuple incarné par la première Assemblée
nationale c'est tout simplement qu'il
veut acclimater en France le modèle
britannique de monarchie
constitutionnelle
finalement ce sont presque les Anglais
qui firent la Révolution française
la famille régnante n'était pas d'accord
et la France évolua vers un autre
système la République naît le 21
septembre il y a
231 ans jour pour jour
ainsi ont toujours vécu nos deux peuples
s'observant
s'influençant longtemps rivaux mais
depuis plus d'un siècle toujours alliés
pour défendre la démocratie et les
droits de l'homme
le calendrier mémorial est là pour nous
le rappeler l'année prochaine en 2024
nous célébrons tout à la fois les 120
ans de l'entente cordiale et le 80ème
anniversaire du débarquement nous nous
reverrons donc comme le chantier
verraline pour continuer de sceller ce
pacte d'amitié et selon partenariat qui
nous unit sur ce qui est essentiel
aujourd'hui
la guerre est revenue sur le sol
européen
et dès lors que les valeurs les plus
fondamentales se trouvent menacées par
un usage illégal et illégitime de la
force nos deux pays se retrouvent une
fois de plus du même côté celui du droit
international et du respect des droits
de l'homme
deux membres permanents du Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies deux membres
de l'OTAN de démocratie d'influence
capable de s'entendre cela compte dans
un monde en proie aux tentatives de
déstabilisation et de désinformation
enfin en tant que femme
première présidente d'une assemblée
parlementaire française je voudrais
saluer la mémoire de ces femmes qui
plutôt qu'en France ont su faire évoluer
les mentalités pour que soit reconnue
les mêmes droits aux deux moitiés du
genre humain
j'aurais donc une pensée pour ces
suffragettes anglaises qui observent
gain de cause dès 1918 et je veux croire
que c'est en observant les femmes
britanniques leur engagement leur
civisme dans les épreuves de la guerre
et du Blitz que le général de Gaulle
signa l'ordonnance du 21 avril min 21
avril 1944 qui rendit enfin les
Françaises et lectrices et éligibles
à Londres aussi pendant la guerre un
jeune français qui avait rejoint la
France Libre découvrit qu'on pouvait
acheter en pharmacie des produits
anti-conceptionnels permettant aux
femmes de contrôler leur natalité il
s'appelait Lucien Neuville futur député
et futur sénateurs qui obtiendra en 1967
la légalisation de la pilule en France
au moment où dans le monde et jusque
dans de grandes démocraties les droits
des femmes sont remis en question sur la
base d'un discours nataliste agressif il
est bon de rappeler cet épisode qui est
beaucoup plus qu'une anecdote la liberté
ne se segmente pas on est libre ou on ne
l'est pas
et nous voulons l'être dans toutes les
dimensions de la vie
si
nos deux démocraties continueront
d'avancer ainsi vers notre idéal commun
de liberté et de respect de la personne
humaine
chacune à son pas chacune à sa manière
mais toujours main dans la main quand il
faut être ferme
ainsi je sais qu'ensemble nous
avancerons et ferons avancer le monde
sur la préservation de l'environnement
et de la biodiversité cause pour lequel
nous savons votre investissement
personnel depuis votre jeunesse sur cet
enjeu majeur sur cette grande question
du Millénaire
Marianne et Britannia resteront deux
sœurs
comme le déclarant Winston Churchill à
la Chambre des communes
[Musique]
le Tout-Puissant dans son infini sagesse
n'a pas jugé bon de créer les Français à
l'image des Anglais
et il disait aussi la France et la
Grande-Bretagne ont trouvé le chemin de
la liberté par des voies bien
différentes mais tant qu'elles feront
cause commune il sera bien dangereux de
les provoquer et bien difficile de les
abattre
cire il est impossible en quelques
minutes de résumer des siècles de
voisinage et de partenariats multiples
mais je sais que nous nous comprenons
pour continuer à faire ainsi cause
commune nos deux pays qui se sont mis
d'accord pour restaurer et entretenir la
Tapisserie de Bayeux sauront donné une
suite enthousiasmante à cette première
bande dessinée de l'histoire c'est tout
le sens de votre visite et c'est
pourquoi je suis fier et heureuse de
vous dire au nom de la représentation
nationale bienvenue en France
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]